36 percent from three during these
playoffs nice Century pass yogic Gordon
with a couple of dunks early on
Gordon very aggressive gets another one
to go and Gordon with six early points
Caldwell Polk throws it back deflect
right back to him
and Murray sets it up Gordon again
aggressively goes right into the paint
scores again Baron corbs got four field
goals already played just over five
minutes Denver likes to push the pace
Miami gets back nicely
Gordon goes right at Vincent Aaron
Gordon double figures already they've
had good looks
Wharton season opening Euro stat
left-handed Aaron Gordon
bursting out of the gate here in game
one
already on the drive
again the entry pass and Gordon Banks at
home nine assists for yoga